[Music]
hello and happy New Year welcome to the
week in 60 minutes brought to you by
spectator TV and broadcast on Thursday
the 4th of January I'm Kate Andrews The
Spectators economics editor and your
host this week coming up on the
show Owen Matthews writes this week's
cover piece on Vladimir Putin's
so-called peace plan for Ukraine he'll
be on the show with Mark giati to
discuss whether a ceasefire is really
possible and under what terms it might
be negotiated sticking with foreign
affairs I'll speak to Arash aizi about
whether direct conflict between Iran and
Israel is looming and lonel Shriver
about which is a bigger threat to
American democracy this year the
political left or the political right
back in the UK what troubles does Rishi
sunak have ahead of him this month I'll
speak to James heel was Churchill really
a progressive Sinclair McKay will join
me and lastly do box tickers now rule
the office I'll speak to Rory
southernland before we get going if you
enjoy spectator TV do subscribe to our
YouTube channel just click the Subscribe
button at the bottom of this video and
tap the Bell icon to make sure you never
miss an
episode first up Owen Matthews writes
this week's cover piece about how
Vladimir Putin hopes to partition
Ukraine president zalinsky Owen writes
could be pressured into negotiating a
ceasefire soon Owen joins me on the show
now alongside spectator contributor mark
iotti Owen and Mark thanks for joining
spectator TV Owen you write the cover
piece for this week's magazine about the
possibility of a socalled peace deal in
Ukraine tell us about recent reports
that suggest that something could be in
the works uh well first and foremost um
let's be very clear we're not talking
about a peace deal we're talking about a
ceasefire and those are actually two
very really important things um I think
uh ceasefire is something that Putin has
reportedly and uh uh I know personally
the reporters that worked on this for
the New York Times who reported it on
23rd of December and they have very good
sources and uh uh their information is
that there have been unofficial
backchannel feelers from the Kremlin to
uh senior officials in Washington to
discuss the possibility of a ceasefire
ceasefire not necessarily a peace deal
but a ceasefire um essentially freezing
the conflict along the line of control
and uh I find that uh pretty plausible
actually because um that kind of deal
um that kind of arrangement that kind of
ceasefire allows Putin to sort of lock
in a situation on the ground that he
hopes is going to become a de facto
eventual partition of Ukraine um but the
point of my piece this week is um that
although Putin putting out peace feelers
or wanting to talk is not necessarily
news what's really news is that I think
uh what US policy policy makers are
starting to realize is that um one
essential ingredient of any kind of
eventual ceasefire or post-war
Arrangement or end game orever you like
to call it is
essentially dividing Ukraine and
allowing Putin to keep the part that
he's already occupied and that comes
with
enormous uh moral hazard and practical
problems Mark do you agree with Owen's
characterization of Putin's thinking
after the Christmas assault on Ukraine
can we take these calls
seriously we can because it's for
entirely pragmatic reasons look on the
one hand Putin clearly has a a wider
goal of actually wanting to essentially
subordinate Ukraine remove it from being
part of as he sees it the West's sphere
of influence and bring it back into his
but essentially Putin is also deeply
pragmatic he's aware that this is an
exceedingly expensive politically and
economic War for himself and although
this coming year is unfortunately
looking quite good for the Russians they
have an advantage in terms of ammunition
the ukrainians are probably going to
have to spend the year essentially
rebuilding after their rather
unsuccessful counter offensive and so
forth once you start getting into 2025
and Beyond there's actually some real
risks for the Russians so I can see
Putin thinking well this is a good time
precisely to regard this as as some as a
high Watermark of of of Russian
occupation let's try and freeze it now
through the the medium of a ceasefire if
things change dramatically
then I can I can always break the
ceasefire it's not as though Putin
regards himself as being sort of bound
by these kind of agreements but on the
other hand it also poses a great dilemma
for the West because let's be perfectly
honest not only are there many countries
in the west that would frankly rather
not be spending what it costs to support
support Ukraine but also particularly in
Washington there is a a
growing almost Terror of what might
happen were Donald Trump to win the
presidency and certainly for some people
within the blob I mean I'm encountering
it in my own conversations with with
officials there is that sense of we
can't let this war roll on until it
becomes Donald Trump's playground we
actually have to reach some kind of of a
settlement before that point which makes
them really quite vulnerable to this
kind of suasion from Moscow oh and I
want to pull up the cover image here
because I I think it makes the point
really well that when we talk about a
peace deal some kind of deal a ceasefire
uh these words don't necessarily reflect
reality H it has been a big talking
point from the beginning of this
conflict that agreeing to some sort of
peace deal would legitimize Putin's
Terror and what he's done but there's
also a bigger question for ukrainians
about whether or not it just gives him
more time to regroup and come back even
stronger when we talk about all of these
options whatever name we put on them are
we really talking about a safer World
particularly for
Ukraine uh yeah I think that that's
absolutely right I mean as as uh as Mark
completely correctly has said and has
argued for many years the the the key
feature of the Putin regime has always
been this absolutely ruthless uh um
pragmatism and the fact that they
constantly adapt situations and uh it's
very hard to actually read any kind of
grand
strategy or let me put that differently
I mean although a grand strategy may
exist um uh there in in the Kremlin in
Putin's mind there are usually several
such Grand strategies running in
parallel and actually they just sort of
chop and change between them all the
time we've seen that time and time again
you know Over Georgia over Syria um over
over Crimea and so on they you know they
they they basically Putin will take
whatever he can get um the the the the
the the problem is um the really
fundamental difficulty is that a Forever
War does not favor Ukraine So currently
there's a major disconnect between the
official position of uh zilinski and his
inner team which is that we need to
fight on until the end uh we need to
persuade the West to give her the
weapons um that we need to fight the war
although in parenthesis it's not really
clear having had the weapons they have
what further escalation is going to be
required to actually achieve the goal of
returning 1991 borders I mean that's a
lot of of equipment but there's a
fundamental disconnect between that
zinsky position that we need to going to
keep fighting until Russia is defeated
and the actual future of Ukraine because
actually although the war as marus said
is expensive uh for Russia it's still um
building up its uh its its military
capabilities it's getting stronger I
would say not weaker um over time and
meanwhile Ukraine is losing its main uh
asset um tragically which is its people
and the Ukraine faces the a terrible
shortage of uh of men to recruit for the
front lines and we already see some some
fractures appearing in Ukrainian Society
so in a nutshell you have a
contradiction and a problem because
actually a long endless war does not
favor Ukraine it probably favors Russia
uh and at the same time the longer the
war goes on the longer Ukraine has to
wait to actually reconstruct itself
reform itself and sail off into its
bright European future none of that can
happen until a ceasefire happens or
until the conflict is somehow resolved
Mark what do you make of those comments
that a longer war is more difficult for
Ukraine How likely is it that Ukraine
could win back some of that remaining
land and do you think the Ukrainian
people are ready to accept some kind of
deal that doesn't include all of that
land being returned when asked the
straightforward up and down question of
should we fight on until we have
achieved victory victory being defined
in terms of regaining all the occupied
territories a majority a very clear
majority of ukrainians still say yes but
in some ways that's misleading because
that is if nothing else an appeal to
patriotism people know what the quote
unquote right answer is what's
interesting is I know there's been focus
group work talking to trying to talk to
ukrainians about particular objectives
and essentially what would you think is
an acceptable cost in terms of lives and
Owen is absolutely right I mean although
the Russians have lost a lot more men
proportionate to population Ukraine is
suffering greater than the Russians so
you know what do you think needs to be
spent and you know when we look at for
example Crimea a lot of ukrainians
frankly are probably not thinking that
it's worth the likely cost of regaining
this peninsula many of whose inhabitants
especially now that there's been about
million Russian colonists arriving
currently you know many of whose
inhabitants therefore actually want to
be Russian rather than Ukrainian I
remember once talking to a Ukrainian
interior Minister official fairly senior
who was concerned that basically he said
Crimea could be our Northern irand so I
mean for all these reasons you know one
has to go beyond that overall sort of
current determination to regain all the
territory I think that certainly in the
west but also amongst quite a few
figures within Kev there is a quiet
awareness that someday some deal will be
struck the problems are two one is no
one wants to say so publicly for fear of
being pillared especially so long as
zalinsky himself is so fervently
committed to a full maximalist kind of
Victory but the second thing is in some
ways no one wants to show their hand
before any
negotiations the sense being if you more
or less admit that you for example might
not want Crimea then in a way the
Russians would take as read well we've
got Crimea what else can we get so this
is the trouble at the moment in a way it
is waiting for someone to be the first
person to to make that kind of move
Putin thinks time is on his side so he's
not willing to do it zinski also thinks
I think time is on his side so for that
reason neither of the leaders really at
this moment are willing to make those
kind of tough self-abnegating choices
which negotiations will involve oh and
Mark just mentioned president zalinski
what are his positions publicly but
perhaps more importantly privately on
this issue of a
deal well uh as far as I understand it
his private position is pretty much the
same as his public position is that they
um uh they realize um that there's a
fatal um there's a
fatal Cascade that begins in your war
effort if you start to decide that you
are talking and once once you announce
that you know you actually
immediately basically pull the carpet in
terms of morale and in terms of you know
no one wants to be in a famously John
kery said no one wants to be the last
man to die for a mistake and that's the
and that's the the Colossal problem for
for for for zilinski in admitting any
kind of negotiation furthermore by the
way last October zilinski actually wrote
into law that negotiations with the
Putin regime was literally illegal so he
literally is not able to do that until
he changes his in law I it's a kind of
strange kind of thing to write into law
but nonetheless I mean that zilinski did
it to Signal his resolve not one step
back but at the same time uh you see um
growing discontent uh or not discontent
but certainly like the return of
politics let's put it like that in Kiev
and by a gigantic irony the only thing
that is actually keeping zalinski the
main thing is keeping zalinski popular
and keeping Ukraine United is um Putin's
appalling attacks you know absent the
Christmas and New Year bombardment which
was which has been among the heaviest of
of of the war you would actually see
actually very rather serious uh uh
fishes and debates developing in in
Ukrainian society and I just spent three
weeks in Kiev and uh I spoke to lots of
people for for in know current and
former zalinsky uh senior ministers and
um and and advisers and uh the those who
oppose him or CH you know who would
under normal circumstances speak out
prefer not to because you know it's
you it's not the time to to do it now
that we're under attack but um there is
actually you know growing ground sell of
opinion that zilinski actually has
mismanaged the war and not that we
should like surrender put up our hands
and and hand over the territories but
certainly there's some kind of uh
there's some kind of um uh U compromise
has to be reached with the Russians and
if you look as as Mark rightly said the
Ukrainian people's opinion it all
depends very much on on the question you
ask is because if you ask a slightly
different question and it was asked at
the beginning of December do you think
that some kind of compromise is
necessary uh uh um uh to end this war um
then 43% of ukrainians surveyed by um
well respected K pollster said yes and
46% no so I mean you know clearly
there's a very large min minority of
ukrainians that are actually kind of
willing to not not only willing to do a
deal or but but willing to publicly
admit that a deal needs to be done Mark
last question in his new year's address
Putin didn't really mention his war in
Ukraine it seems like he wants to
distractor even move on from the
conflict when it comes to those kinds of
public speeches if there were some kind
of a deal we can pretty much assume that
regardless of what it looked like money
would be pouring into Ukraine from the
West immediately to help it rebuild we
cannot say the same about the West
reaction to Russia would Putin be
allowed to return to activity as usual
even if a peace deal were secured well
look there's no question that we'd
return to some kind of status quo anti
even if there was some kind of not just
a ceasefire but an actual peace deal
probably we would see some kind of
sanctions relief as a necessary part of
that deal but even so I mean essentially
we're entering a future in which at
least as long as Putin is in the Kremlin
there will be continued controls over
the export of Technology over investment
into Russia and so forth I mean we we
are heading back into a Cold War era in
that respect so you know again it won't
just simply be a sort of Kum by Our
Moment where we all just sort of pretend
that it that this Gastly war never
happened but that said I think from from
Putin's point of view he is in a
position in which actually he is
constrained I think more by his own
sense of his historic Destiny his place
in in in sort of the basically the
pantheon of Russian statebuilding
Heroes rather than pressure from below
it is not actually as if most Russians
are sitting there saying and go go back
to the example that Owen gave that so
aiva must be ours they don't want to
lose but that's you know but not wanting
to be defeated is different from
actually having some kind of clear
objectives if Putin were able to
negotiate something that looked like a
piece and looked like a piece from his
point of view with honor and remember he
controls the media so he has
considerable freedom to spin whatever
happens as as some kind of honorable
success if he can do that then I think
the Russian people will be quite
accepting of that but as I say I think
I'm not I think Putin himself in this
respect is is the constraint he will
know that it won't really be a victory
and I think he may well not feel that
that is either politically s survivable
for him or the Legacy that he wants to
go down in
history Owen and Mark thanks so much for
joining spectator
TV it appears Israel was behind the
assassination of a senior hos figure in
Lebanon earlier this week is the attack
assigned that direct conflict between
Israel and Iran is getting closer I'm
joined Now by Arash aizi author of what
Iranians want Arash thank you for
joining spectator TV the deputy
political leader of Hamas Salah aluri
was killed in Lebanon earlier this week
it looks like an Israeli air strike what
was your
reaction um it's clear that Israel was
going to take uh serious revenge on
Hamas leadership um and and kill people
responsible of course their uh their
most U sort of the target they really
want most is Muhammad Dave who was in
Gaza and and is very likely to have been
The Mastermind um of the October 7th uh
terrorist attacks um but Salah harui is
is also a very high ranking figure
importantly Rudy had a very important
role role in linking Hamas to the Islam
Republic of Iran the Iranian regime and
the irgc the militia that rules things
in Iran um and we have to remember the
Iranian regime is the only serious uh
state in the region that supports uh
Hamas and its um you know sort of
militarily um so killing aruri was uh
clearly a a sort of Target for Israelis
um it's also though the fact that they
killed him by a strike um in in Lebanese
territory in in in Beirut uh uh which
will which sort of does escalate um and
and you know does increase the risk of a
broader configration and bringing in
Lebanon to this even further well yes
analysts and politicians have been
warning since the start of this war that
Israel could end up in an allout war
with Lebanon and Hezbollah this is
obviously an attack on a hamos figure
but it was inside of Lebanon is this the
beginning of an
escalation um well
there you know there's always a risk of
an of an escalation but um if I was to
guess I would say that there are some
positive signs that um that we won't
have really a broader configration and
the basic reason for that is that
neither Israel nor Iran uh in the
leadership of neither these countries
want such a configration
um um so sort of a serious Regional war
that that would involve them directly
against each other um because that could
be truly destructive on on really
massive scale of course the scale of
Destruction in Gaza for the people of
Gaza is already as massive as it could
be for the people of Gaza but this could
open up uh you know to the lives of tens
of millions of people in the region um
and be really destructive and dangerous
for the Iranian regime and for Israel
itself so um I think the danger is
always there and one has to work against
it things are escalated again there was
this um terror attack in in Iran today
it's not clear who did it but it's one
of the deadliest ter attacks in Ran
history more than 100 people were killed
which which really will escalate things
I I think it's most likely caused by
sort of a terror group like Isis but at
any at any rate what it will do is will
escalate the tensions and there is
always a possibility of a broader
configuration but um certainly killing
arui hasn't gotten us there yet and it
won't do so very easily in this attack
in Iran it's estimated that more than 70
people have been killed it was at
commemoration for cassm solomani can you
remind our viewers who solomani is and
tell us more of what you make of the
news particularly in relation to
Israel's relationship with Iran and
potential escalation
there sumani was the head of the
external vings of the irgc this militia
that really rules things in Iran these
days um he was The Mastermind of Iran
R's an alliance and support for Hamas
and Palestinian Islamic Jihad but also
by Hezbollah in Lebanon H is in Yemen a
group that forms a government in parts
of Yemen and has been um sort of firing
rockets in Israel and at other sort of
ships going on on the Red Sea um solmani
was a was a lynchpin of Iran's
relationship with the Syrian government
of Bashar Assad and he had actually very
important role by bringing Putin's and
Russian intervention there so he was
really this um this Grand figure and and
and a high ranking figure who was killed
in on January 3rd 2020 uh by uh by a USS
strike now the January 3rd is usually a
very tense day in the fourth anniversary
as I said we've seen this Grand terror
attack look it's very early on um but I
can say um by my own estimation if you
ask me right now this is a speculation
is a bit of an informed guest but I
would think the most likely culate is a
group like Isis Isis horasan for example
the group's Regional branch in
Afghanistan or a similar domestic or or
sort of foreign terror group um now it's
not impossible that Israel could have
been involved but there's no so far
there is no indication of Israeli
involvement um and also none of the
leading Iranian officials like the
interior Minister Ahmed vahidi or the
head of the Judiciary uh you know those
who have spoken none of them have
pointed fingers at Israel yet um and
there's also some analysts say that even
if this you know Iranian regime would be
very careful at doing so because of
course then if if it fingers in Israel
that that means that it would have to
retaliate which is which as I said is
something that it doesn't want to
necessarily do the Iranian regimes and
the leadership of Ali it's his supreme
leader um has brought a lot of
instability to this region but he's also
been very careful to save his ownin and
that of his regime by not getting Iran
into a broad of War so that's likely his
the kind of decision making we're going
to see from him um in in the days to
come which is not so dissimilar to
decision- making by Benjamin Netanyahu
prime minister of Israel who also also
is not actually sort of a guy who who
sort of wants to get his country into a
very broad War usually even though he
now finds himself in a deadly conflict
with Hamas and Gaza um but because of
you know what we know about K Netanyahu
and not to mention Biden in the United
States which would be critical in any
decision making on parts of Israel um
none of these figures would like a
broader configuration and that's U
that's something that militates against
it of although of of course conflicts
happen all the time even though when
none of the sides really want it so the
danger is there we've also seen the
houthi a rebel group in Yemen backed by
Iran causing havoc in the Red Sea
targeting Merchant ships Iran the US and
the UK have all deploy battleships to
the area are all of these incidents part
of the same proxy
story they they are and they aren't um
they are in the sense that the axis of
resistance um this uh umbrella of groups
uh that is backed by it is backed by rgc
group in Iran it has there's ideological
unity in it they are anti-western
they're
anti-israeli um um and you know they
have these commonalities they have same
sort of similar Heroes they have a and
Iran has really tried irgc the Iranian
regime have tried in the past couple of
decades to really build them up bring
them up closer make them more military
sophisticated if you look at the history
of the houis there used to be a mostly
tribal based um Insurgency in in Yemen
in nor in Yemen and and really made S as
a part of the architecture of that
country but the rgc officials as I've as
I've outlined in my work before really
tried to make them into what they
considered a proper ideological
revolutionary group um they made their
sort of you know the hotis had a very
still on the flag of the houes it says
you know death to Israel death to
America but it also says damned the Jews
which really shows they had sort of a
very unsophisticated anti semitism and
then the Iranian regime has tried to
make it into a more ideological I mean
of course it's still anti-semitic but
also and ideological um what they
consider a revolutionary islamist uh
Vision so they are a part of uh same
theater of operations and they do make
sense all as part of this tan backed
axis of resistance but at the same time
there is not a uh Central uh command you
know sort of headquarters where they um
you know make decisions for example now
we believe that uh you know Israeli
intelligence itself believes as Ana Feer
recently wrote in an article in The
Spectator Israeli intelligence uh
believes that the Iranian leadership did
not know about the Hamas attacks of of
October 7th before they occurred so this
really shows you that there's a
considerable degree of autonomy that
each of these groups uh can have and and
they don't run their every single
decision uh by by tan and by K and when
we look at the um we look at the
meetings that the Iranian officials
usually have with houti leadership or
other groups we can sometimes see that
if you read be beyond the uh
statements which they say oh we pledge
full support do whatever you want we can
see that there's sometimes actually a
bit of a risk slapping because you know
unlike this Terror groups Iran is a
major estate in the region is worried
about um getting itself into a what
would be a suicidal and deadly um
conflict direct conflict with with
Israel you mentioned the anel feffer
piece in this week's magazine where he
writes that Iran is losing hold of its
proxies at the end of last month he
writes the Revolutionary guard spokesman
said that hamas's 7th of October attack
was a retaliation for the death of
solomani and Hamas pushed back and said
no it wasn't is it normal to see Hamas
push back on Iran in that kind of
way um well as I have written before uh
for the spectator also Iran and Hamas
has had a Shifty relationship there has
been times when they when they directly
clashed but in this case um so Hamas uh
criticized the I spokesperson but that
that meant that he had to make a very
humilating
um sort of Retreat himself so Sharif the
spokesperson of rgc and the leadership
of the rgc salami who's the main
commander of the irgc basically they
said he had misspoke this was not an
attack to Revenge solmani the Revenge
will do it differently which was really
humilating on the part of the irgc um
but it also further and really what
we've seen since October 72 now um is
that uh the Irani regime plays a game at
first you know it sort of it really
appraises Hamas for its attacks it gives
full political support to the attack the
entire Iranian TV for months now has
been about the war in Gaza and full
support for Hamas and Palestinian
Islamic Jihad at the same time they go
out of their way to say the Palestinian
theater is separate Iran was not
directly involved this is you know and
they sort of use terms like saying oh
this is Palestinian Ingenuity they're
doing it by themselves we're just
supporting it because as I said every
sign indicates that Ali the leadership
of the Islamic Republic does not want to
see a direct conflict uh with Israel for
the the basic reason that I mean I think
it's it's uh I think it's quite clear
that any sort of a direct confrontation
can very can really be suicidal uh for
the regime and of course terrible uh and
to be clear terrible uh for in in terms
of consequences for the peoples of this
region it would open a Pandora box with
really um unpredictable uh consequences
um and it's something that should be
avoided at all costs rash thank you so
much for joining
me lonel Shriver writes for her column
in this week's magazine about how the
political left and right in America will
react if their candidate loses this
year's election is violence on American
streets a possibility either way Lionel
joins me now Lionel thanks for joining
spectator TV you write for your column
this week about a political conversation
that you had with your expat guests over
Christmas tell us about
it well we were trying to decide what
would be uh worse on the
ground um if uh Trump wins or Biden wins
in November um who who would be the
sorest
losers and uh my the company I was
sharing was um typically for most of the
people I know um liberal uh universally
Democrats and they were convinced that
the uh what we should really fear is the
reaction of the right if Trump loses
again that these are the people who have
all the guns and you know there's that
horrible president of January 6th and uh
so you know we'll be uh it would be
we'll be better off with Biden as
president but we would have to pay for
it with a horrible backlash on the right
and of course uh
Democrats are always claiming that uh
democracy itself the Republic itself is
is in
danger um I differed I I I was the only
person who thought that uh if Trump
wins uh not only do are we stuck with
Trump but the left would be likely to go
bananas and I you know I've been through
this rehearsal before because of course
course we play faced the same situation
in 2020 right so one of the reasons I
was relieved when Biden won was not only
that I had voted for him but uh I so
dreaded the response of the left if
Trump prevailed well L let's look at
your column and the two possibilities
that that you and your friends broadly
discuss your friends are talking about
the disgruntle Trump voters how if they
lose again they'll feel the election was
stolen again and you could see some kind
of repeat of January 6 an attempted
Insurrection that could be even more
violent you point out that in the
aftermath of George Floyd you had Al be
a minority but certainly some protesters
who turned very violent and in places
like Seattle and Portland Oregon
essentially took over parts of the city
in in a very violent Manner and the
point here being that in either
direction you you could see something
really quite scary I suppose the
meaningful difference though is that
Trump was the first president to
essentially say that he he would not
accept the results of the election the
Republicans were tested in 2020 and
Donald Trump and his supporters failed
Biden has not been tested in that way
the Democrats haven't been tested at the
presidential level in that way well we
don't really um we don't have the
evidence on the left because the left
has not been tested in this circumstance
I mean the the one bit of evidence we do
have is from 2016 and there was a
concerted 4-year effort to deny uh to
effectively deny Trump the presidency
and to uh invalidate his election uh
which the the Democrats don't like to
remember because they are fixated on
Trump's insistence on invalidating 2020
but there is a a ver there is a a strong
symmetry there um on the uh on the left
versus right you
know January 6 I I found it very
disturbing
um it was a horrific picture to
broadcast all over the world uh of the
US capital being invaded by a a mob and
so I don't play it down exactly except
that I have striven mightily to Main
maintain a sense of proportion about it
I don't think it was an attempt to
overthrow the government of the United
States it was not well
organized it was unarmed um I don't
think there was any expectation in that
crowd that they would actually be able
to get into the capital they all you
know on the CCTV footage they all look
kind of amazed and and baffled and and
wondrous and they're taking selfies and
this this is not an army
which is out to overthrow any government
um and if you look at the
consequences uh the consequences were
mostly for the Democrats being able to
uh use that event politically as a cudel
and of course the people that they were
able to get hold of were
prosecuted I think quite
disproportionately um but in
comparison uh the riots after uh George
Floyd's death were they were all over
the country over 140 cities uh there was
fantastic Damage Done um massive arson
and
vandalism um
and I and it went on for months so I
mean and and and as you noted the cities
like Seattle and Portland have never
been the same
you know and and for the most part these
riots were allowed to go nuts the law
enforcement because it was under attack
ideologically because this was the
defund the police
period laid back in a lot of
metropolitan areas and just let it
happen and for the most part um the
people who caused all that destruction
have not been held to account either so
why wouldn't they do it again
so if I'm looking at
November then that's what makes me no
most nervous lonel you and I have not
been always painted in a nice light over
the past four three and a half years for
our open and public decision to support
Joe Biden in November 20120 and you and
I have spoken about this um when we've
seen each other in person here at The
Spectator offices that people will often
say to us oh gosh you must you must
regret that if you could go back to
election day surely you would recap your
vote for another person um and I think
both of us resly say no I wouldn't and
with the information we had and
certainly uh with hindsight with what
came on January 6 I I do not regret that
vote at all um I have I would I would
love to know your thoughts on that if if
if you have any regrets what I will say
though is I Joe Biden sold himself on
this idea that we might return to some
sanity that we might return to some
normality not in terms of any particular
piece of public policy just the way that
we carry our conversations and political
debate it seems like we're in a worse
spot now perhaps than we were in
November 2020 um and I think that goes
back to the point you were making at the
start about how on Earth we're being
asked to choose between these two
directions perspectives and Men again
yeah I I guess I I agree with you that I
wouldn't take my boat back in
um that said I feel that I've been
victimized by a bait and switch and that
everything that Biden promised he has
gone back on he's been anything but a
unifier you know all that screaming
about Maga Republicans and he's been
he's he's increased the polarization and
he's certainly sold out to the far left
of his party
and I have not been happy with
his with his policies he's been
completely all of his appointments from
day one were completely controlled by
identity politics so that all that
mattered uh about his cabinet or his
staff were uh whether they were gay or
uh uh indigenous or black you know it's
it and it was advertised as much they
were never sold in terms of their
qualifications so that you know that
made me a little concerned from the
outset and and you know he spent too
much money um I'm I'm deeply
disappointed in Biden so I don't want
people to misunderstand me that oh yay
go Biden um lenel nothing you've said
has come across is oh yeah go byen um
but
uh I I have to admit that coming up on
the election I mean I I always vote uh
even if I'm out of the country I make
sure to get an absentee
ballot I just I don't know what I'm
going to do I don't know whom I'm going
to vote for I cannot imagine voting for
either one of them and I I can see
myself choosing some third party who
doesn't have a chance which is a kind of
cheating it's it's it's it's it's
dodging your responsibility if you vote
for a third party and you are usually in
in the context of of a American politics
you are usually tacitly supporting one
or the other candidates who has a prayer
right so i' cautiously I'd cautiously
encourage it of course depending on who
the candidates are depending on the
party my perspective is H we don't owe
them anything we don't have to play
their game your vote is yours and if
nobody in the te- major parties
convinces you I think you're welcome to
look elsewhere um I'm very curious as to
whether Americans might this time round
um there's always talk of third party
candidates they never really get
traction but this is a really unique set
of circumstances where we're being asked
to replay the most horrible election
nobody wants to do it again well I I
think that's probably what I would do I
but I I have to say I I don't feel good
about it and unless the polls really
turn around and and I'm talking about a
third party whom I can consa
support and has a
chance than I then I would vote for that
person with a clear conscience but if
they don't have a
chance um then I think I'm kidding
myself and and and dodging dodging a
choice I don't want to make and
uh and and I I do I think that's that's
a a kind of self the seat it's
it's someone's going to be president
right so even though we don't want to
make a choice between these two men from
the perspective of right now one of them
is going to be president so we have to
decide which one is worse well ler we're
going to have to be in touch because I
think both of us are really quite
miserable right now we can send each
other like the worst of all the
candidates and then figure out who's the
least bad over the course of the year
but I'm pleased got to spend some time
with Americans for Christmas thanks for
joining spectator
TV it's a new year but Richi suak
problems remain largely the same in the
Magazine's politics column this week our
political correspondent James heel
writes about the next round of battles
for sunac to tell us about it James is
on the show now James thanks for joining
me on spectator TV you write the
political column for this week's
magazine and you say that richy sunak is
dealing with some serious January blues
one of the problems being that he has to
clear up his messaging to voters
yes and I think that's why we're seeing
a bit of a reset right now in terms of
uh how they're communicating with the
public today on Thursday rich sunak is
going to be doing this town hall uh to
voters in the East Midlands and it's
going to be behind closed doors which
means that you have Regional journalists
there but not National journalists I
think this is a big shift because um
previously there have been lots of sort
of speeches you remember the Net Zero
speech obviously the conference speech
and I think that really we talking to
Tori MPS over Christmas there's a sense
of what is going to be our narrative
what is going to be the thing we
campaign on you think 20 they had change
2015 it was the long economic plan 2017
2019 it was brexit to various extent and
um I think this time it's like what is
the big theme and that's why we're
seeing right now I think um number 10
opting for these kind of closed door
events and things like Facebook
advertising spending rather than what K
is doing today which is a big speech
national press Etc in the west country
so um I think that's going to be one to
look out for ahead uh as the Tes trying
and work out when the election's going
to be and what message they're going to
run on and it's not just the messaging
he has to clear up with his potential
voters it's also with his own MPS and
you note in the piece that the Rwanda
bill is coming back um and that's going
to be a difficult moment for the Prime
Minister because um The Divide within
the party right now is some MPS want to
soften that bill others think that it
needs to be tightened they just about
managed to to keep everybody in line on
the other side for Christmas but at some
point you're going to have to make clear
to one of those sides well we're going
in the other direction aren't you well
that seems to be what the MPS themselves
are thinking and I think there are some
on the Tory left have indicated they
won't vote for it of course that means
they can just abstain simply and and the
government does have a 60 seat majority
um and I do think a lot of pressure is
going to come from the right and a
couple of issues they're really focusing
on one of which is under this bill the
right to for individual migrants to
appeal their claim and the other is
about um the injunction orders and the
discretion role of ministers to block
those orders um and they want that to be
they concern that you know the minister
is going to be charge of that it's the
Attorney General right now it's Victoria
Apprentice someone uh seen as being on
the tor left and they're concerned
conser much the conserved WR is
concerned that actually that means they
wouldn't use those powers to the full
and so it's one of those things where
they said oh don't worry we'll have a
ministerial discretion but actually it's
one of those things in politics we'
never done so I think there's going to
be a big pressure when that comes back
we're expecting that I think the third
week of January um and then there's
going to be the committee stage and I
think amendments put down so those two
issues will be something of amendments I
think the other thing to look out for is
whether we'll have outright withdrawal
from the ECR and the key question is uh
Kate is that for a lot of trps are
thinking well you know a lot of the
delivery stage has been done with this
government there's not so much you can
do there going to be felt On The Ground
by an election say in October let alone
may so the Rwanda bill has kind of
really seen as totemic and so I think it
could be one of those things like just
like in 1997 when the Tory uh the Tory
line was on an easy compromise between
uh Ken Clark and John Major on the
question of the Euro membership um
actually Ator um MPS coming up on the
back benches and just in the that
campaign saying well this maybe the
official line but my view is I will
never join the Euro and that obviously
caused a huge problem around um message
discipline Etc and the same is true of
this time which is that you could see
very likely I think um Rich for instance
in an election say well I'm going to do
XY Z on injunction orders and then you
could see certain members of say for
instance the new conservatives stand up
and say well I'm actually going to pull
out the echr and of course that then
leads into these questions of Tory
splits divides Etc at a time when cchq
would love to push the message that
labor the real divided party um and so I
think that's going to be something that
plays out throughout the year James
there are a lot of questions about
whether or not the Rwanda bill can get
through Parliament not least because
riak tightens this bill to the rights
liking the randan government has
suggested they might not be comfortable
with it if it in any way perceives to
break international law but to keep this
domestic for the moment if if the right
is happier with this bill because riak
has tightened it up in their Direction
can it still get through Parliament you
mentioned obss there but could this be a
very fragile moment even a breaking
moment for the government yes there's
the real risk of that and getting it
through the commons is the first stage
and then of course you got the house of
laws to consider as well now talking to
people on different sides I think
there's a sense perhaps that the Lords
might actually let it through uh in that
they would consider the bill unlikely to
work so they would the argument would be
look we don't want to get into an
argument of the peers versus the people
let's just let the bill fail on its own
Merit so I think actually talking to
someone the right they're just saying
well look I mean why would they
necessarily oppose it because this bill
isn't going to work anyway and we want
to make it work and make it viable and
so a lot of the the criticisms come back
and this is the problem for rich sunak
in a sense is that they come back to the
arguments made by so bravman and Robert
genrich who until very recently were
serving at in charge of his migration
and Asylum policy so it's not just
necessarily what we saw last year when
we had the Winds of framework vote and
we saw you know I think the ERG was had
been lot of focus on its strength and
numbers Etc and only got about 25 this
is about you know people who were
Central to Run's government Central to
his Rwanda plan as of just you know two
months ago uh now making criticisms
which are picked up and run with by
others so it's a big question when it
comes down to the Amendments I think a
lot of it frankly is we're in quite
uncharted waters and whether it will
work or not and how international law
will work around these things I would
also just stress that it's not just the
you know the UK government that's
looking at of this stuff in terms of the
ECR it's going to be something across
Europe it's going to be a theme I think
that's going to dominate for the next
decade or so uh and lastly James you
mentioned that the labor leader has
given a big speech this morning um it's
supposed to be sort of an
all-encompassing speech about the future
it's very policy light isn't it tell us
about what he said well I thought it was
ground to day watching it today because
he was standing in front of Machinery
robotics Etc and that's exactly the same
setting he gave last year for his
January speech so here we are one year
on what's changed you could say look at
the poll sometimes you wonder about that
but look it it really I think it was
something for everyone in a sense then
you look about this in the pre-briefing
uh of the speech in the speech there was
something for everyone so for instance
um he was talking about we can't just
have politics dressed up with virtue
that was an attempt I think to distance
himself from Jeremy Corbin's era that's
the line that Telegraph run with was
also talk about cleaning up politics
that's the line of the Guardian run with
and I think really as you say it was
more about you know emphasizing
priorities and focus rather than getting
into a big policy heavy agenda um there
are certain merits to that I think one
of the criticisms of say for instance
Corin in 2019 was it was a huge non
policy document we're expecting a
Manifesto much more narrow next time um
and I think what was interesting though
was the way in which he was rehearsing
several themes um you know talking about
the optimism politics being to change
your life and it was very much reminded
me of margarth ater the late '70s don't
just hope for a better life vote for one
and so I think what really the mistake
of the I think press made was when he
talked about Margaret Thatcher in that t
the telegraph oped not too long ago was
saying he wants to you know be Margaret
that now I don't think he's going to be
privatizing stuff left right and Center
what I do think is that he's trying to
um learn and Ape from the successful
habits of successful opposition leaders
and really Mark that language and take
it into government and so I think the
question he's shown is that he can be
good at politics and opposition and the
challenge for now will be can he do that
as prime minister as well how much
longer can he get away with not being
much clearer about the bigger policies
he's going to be asked about we know
about his plans to slap VAT on private
school fees we know about his plans to
change non-dom non we know about his
plans to change non-domiciled tax status
but how much longer can he basically
move around and and not properly address
with those much bigger tax questions um
that affect day-to-day people well the
big one of course is the 28 billion
Green New Deal and I think we're going
to see some M of that later this month
there been reports that he's going to
have some with Rachel Reeves about that
so I think that'll be the the big one to
work out frankly though I mean they've
done pretty well so far with that to
policy so I reckon that they'll be able
to get away with a bit longer I mean I
spoke to one Shadow K member about this
not so long ago and they said well the
problem is when we announce a policy the
conservatives either try to trash it or
they're nicked so they they certainly
see no harm in and holding some of it
back I do think as we get closer to an
election they're doing this these
exercises of trying to work out you play
Devil's Advocate red team
um der Irving tried had a similar role
before 97 where he would go and sort of
intellectually Duff up the shadow
ministers and talk about their policies
Etc so they will be stress testing each
of those as we get closer to it I will
be interested to see how many of those
um policies that survive pre 2021 when
St was in the first phase of his
leadership will make it into that final
Manifesto um but I think it will be more
slimm down because they want to
basically have as few as uh potential
avenues for the conservatives to attack
them on when it comes into that short
general election campaign James thanks
for joining me was Winston Churchill
really a progressive Sinclair McKay says
so in this week's magazine he says that
history trying to cast him as a sexist
or imperialist is wide Off the Mark he
joins me to make his case St Clair is
the 150th anniversary of church Hill's
birth and we live in a world where many
academics end journalists say that he
was racist imperialist sexist your
argument in the sweet's magazine is that
he was a progressive Pioneer tell us why
he was a progressive Pioneer uh because
uh
in in certain flashes of his long life
he lived for 90 years so he was born in
1874 and lived right the way through to
1965 the the the apotheosis of The
Rolling Stones uh a great deals have
changed throughout that time and a great
deal Chang with Churchill too yes he
there were many academics who were
interested in appropriating him as a
model of the racist imperialist
genocidal War Monga um but actually
there's all sorts of different other
sides to Churchill that you see peeking
through like flashes from a diamond all
the way could through his life you
mentioned Church Hill's views on gender
and sexuality apparently he said that in
the next life he'd like to come back as
a woman and yes he was talking to his
cousin CLA Sheridan in 1920 this was
just two years after the end of the the
first World War uh he was very drunk he
was with several friends of his and
Clare Sheridan in a sort of artistic
retreat in Teddington and she came back
one night to discover Churchill and a
very sort of non-binary silk dressing
gown uh with several of his friends uh
absolutely pie eyed on champagne and he
said in the next life I intend to come
back as a woman um you also mentioned in
your you also mentioned in your article
that he had a relationship with Jenny
Lee the labor MP and founder of the open
University who he got on well with what
do you take or what do you read from
that relationship well there are two
different things actually one of the
interesting things about Churchill's
life is this was he he lived at a time
when men generally didn't think that
women should be in politics to begin
with uh and in fact it took him a long
time to come around to to do the
suffragette movement and and votes for
women but also on top of that it was a
time when men found men of his class
particularly found it quite difficult to
talk women to look women directly in the
eye to treat them as equals Churchill
actually had a number of very strong
friendships uh with a number of actually
rather brilliant uh brilliant women uh
Violet asor Jenny Lee being another uh
because another aspect of his life was
that even though he loathed socialism in
his bones uh detested communism uh he
got on terrifically well with his
political opponents Jenny Lee was one of
them she was a Firebrand uh labor MP who
got elected to the house in 1929 she was
very young she was in her 20s so an
extraordinary kind of radical figure to
to land in the House of Commons uh all
the way from all the way up to Scotland
you would have thought just the mortal
enemy of Churchill so Churchill just
made beine for her and she was rather
kind of beguiled by the fact that he was
willing to engage with her and have kind
of proper kind of debates and so he
would have been regarded by her as a
kind of monster but as their as their
friendship went on through to the 1950s
when she was married to
um uh oh to the man who invented n
beavon the man who invented the Health
Service uh even by the 1950s uh she was
she was rather Charmed and beguiled by
by Churchill you also mentioned in your
piece that he may have been slightly
more open-minded on homosexuality than
his peers would have been at the time
absolutely I think in in that sense
church was a curious genuine kind of uh
pioneer uh one of his best friends Eddie
Marsh who was a brilliant uh not only
just a civil servant but a fantastic
kind of art art collector artistic
figure um Eddie Marsh was was not
exactly openly gay but at the same time
didn't exactly disguise it either um and
he was one of church Hill's best friends
closest Associates for many many years
uh Eddie Marsh introduced him to the gay
composer Ivan Noll uh with whom
Churchill also got on to well he was
very great friends with W Somerset M uh
the the the gay novelist and again this
was at a time when homosexuality was
legal uh so none of these figures would
have proclaimed kind of out loud uh
their their orientation but at the same
time it would have been fairly apparent
to to Churchill who had seen a bit of
the world and understood a bit of the
world uh what they and it made no
difference to him others may have shied
away from such friendships for fear of
Scandal for instance but church will
never did you do accept in your piece
that Churchill had quote Grim views on
race what was his Outlook I always
slightly wonder about I mean yes I mean
yes he was racist and people at the time
thought he was racist too it's not it's
not controversial uh to say that but
there are there's different levels to
this uh he was quoted by as being
incredibly rude about the Indian people
for instance and his own friend Leo
Amory who went to school with him at
Harrow uh was horrified by by
Churchill's views on on India but at the
same time there again there are layers
here we think of Churchill as a child of
Empire he was he was brought up in it of
the golden sunsets of Empire uh he lived
its kind of fullest life so it would be
it would that to him was the way the
world worked would have been very
unusual had it been had it been
otherwise but at the same time there are
other instances in that uh I was
thinking of the 1919 amirit arm Massacre
when General Dyer opened fire on on an
unarmed crowd um and it was expected of
Churchill in 1919 that he would stand up
in Parliament and defend General General
dire um and his actions and he didn't he
said that this was this was
frightfulness this is exactly the kind
of thing that Empire shouldn't be doing
Empire should not be founded on Force
because if it's founded on force uh then
the entire point of It kind of fails so
it's he's in many instances you find
actually he's the the opposite of a
genocidal warmonga he's he's much more
human uh than that there is a real
living human underneath the layers of
character of the Church of course
compared to today's standards being
friends with people or not being as
explicitly racist as one might expect in
a moment is a very very low bar I I I I
suppose my question to you is many
people will not accept that Churchill
was pioneering progressivism but they
will still recognize him as an important
historical figure uh do you think that's
fair you think that's right yes I but
what you also see with Churchill is many
of those who now uh seek to write entire
books about how he was a genocidal
warmonger imperialist and all V uh in a
trying to to get control of History
which which is what Churchill himself
was trying to do having written so much
himself over the years uh his own five
volume uh account of uh the second world
war for instance but beyond that he was
always very very piercingly aware of his
own uh part as a landmark of kind of
History even at the time but it's also
important to say it's it's it's now said
that there's a kind of cult of Churchill
that uh that there is kind of un
unreasoning kind of worship of Churchill
and actually that was never the case at
any kind of Point through his life there
were always those who could bitterly
absolutely opposed him and hated him he
was hated by so many Welsh people and
still is uh for his actions at Tony
Pandy in 1910 uh the general strike of
1926 the entire labor movement
abominated Churchill he was he was seen
as a monster to so many of them but on
the other side of that when many of his
opponents came finally into close
contact with them uh they they did see
that there were kind of layers layers of
kind of humor and layers of compassion
too there was the story of the the
Liverpool MP Bessie bradoock who was a
formidable brilliant leftwing figure in
the
1950s uh uh she was implacably opposed
to Churchill there was the famous story
uh where she rounded on Churchill and
said Winston you're drunk and he said
Madam you're ugly but tomorrow I shall
be sober very ungallant I'm not entirely
sure if it actually is true she didn't
even mention it in her memoirs but what
she did say in her memoirs was that uh
they they had various other Encounters
in the house of Commons and she couldn't
help thinking that actually all right
yes he is the greatest living Englishman
he was a monster for 1926 in the general
strike but there are other sides of him
what sort of conservative wierch will be
today where would he fall in the party
oh that's yes that's a very good
question um especially when it comes to
social issues or small L liberal values
yes I mean would he be it's very
difficult to say would he now fall more
on the the Rory Stewart side rather than
the reform
Richard T I I think he' be he wouldn't
be a supporter of Nigel farage I don't
think
that that that kind of simplistic of
populism that bombastic populism would
not be a start at all and as I say there
the layers of subtlety in Churchill's
politics uh he was always open to new he
was in many you know he reformed prisons
for instance which is why I mentioned uh
the the Rory Stewart uh possible uh Ty
uh he was also he
introduced a certain of Trade union
reforms early in the of the 20th century
which meant that unions could not be
sued by employers automatically so every
time we think of church as being an
extreme right-winger you always find a
case of him actually not being an
extreme right-winger at all him
understanding that sometimes the economy
has to be fixed so that working people
who find themselves in distress through
no fault of their own have to be helped
um in that says yes I would
say the the more moderate potentially on
the left of the party very interesting s
CL all the part is at stands at the
moment anyway thanks so much for joining
me thank you very much thank you and
finally our Wiki man colum Miss Rory
southernland says in this week's
magazine that the office has a new
Overlord Rory is on the show now Rory
thank you for joining spectator TV you
write for this week's magazine about the
worrying rise of the office box ticker
who are these people and why are you
concerned about
it well what particularly concerns me is
that always seems to be this strange
phenomenon which is large
companies employ huge numbers of people
relatively few of whom seem to be
principally engaged in effectively
performing the task for which the
company has been hired instead there's
this ever growing bureaucracy I think I
quote in my piece that the amount spent
on HR salaries uh since I think 2017 has
gone from 15 billion to 25 billion a
year and I think it's worth asking
what's going on and I think it comes
down to you know kind of well that old
Latin phrase you know quis custodiat
ipsos custodes and it's the people who
are engaged in effectively
quantifying um or optimizing the
efficiency of the organization never
really apply the same scrutiny to
themselves um and so that so that if
you're a call center worker which is you
know seen as a cost okay as far as the
business is concerned I don't think a
call center worker is a cost I think
it's part of the value a business
creates but it's defined as a cost by
the kind of people in the finance
function your work is scrutinized and
your productivity is obsessed over by
tons and tons of people who would regard
you know 10 minutes making a cup of tea
as you know wasted time meanwhile the
people effectively imposing this
scrutiny never seem to actually shrink
in their numbers they seem just
continuously to grow it's almost a
branch of corporate oncology if you like
and they're not really in fact their
productivity what we do what's the
productivity of your finance department
no one has a clue their productivity
doesn't seem to be scrutinized it
doesn't seem to be measured and weirdly
mysteriously as a proportion of overall
headcount these people never see seem to
do anything except grow uh David gyber
the late Anthropologist actually wrote a
whole piece about this called
jobs in which he theorized that contrary
to the usual kind of idealistic
explanations of private sector
businesses um uh jobs can exist
for all manner of reasons one of which I
think is you know the burden of
Regulation undoubtedly creates more and
more of these jobs uh the fact that you
send more and more people to University
who are some how prepared to do a desk
job but regard being a plumber as
weirdly beneath them that undoubtedly
magnifies the availability of people for
these jobs but also in some cases I
think they're kind of there as a kind of
reputational uh Shoring up mechanism uh
for the Senior Management in the case of
HR who fear a scandal uh or a breach of
something more acutely than they care
about their customers in the short to
medium term that's one explanation uh in
the case of Finance You could argue that
the growth of things like you know the
spreadsheet as a technology has
effectively created this absurd culture
of over
measurement uh which has brought with it
a large number of people whose job is
effectively just effectively channeling
numbers through spreadsheets from one
person to another without any really
clear idea other than the just default
juristic that more information is better
more measurement is better more metrics
are better if you question that
assumption then it's perfectly plausible
that huge sedes of people are being
created and if they ultimately looked at
the uh their
output uh it would be effectively
negative their contribution to the
effect effective running of the company
would almost certainly be negative you
say in your piece that you think that
the uh culture of box ticking is
actually part of the productivity crisis
that we have here in the UK now some a
culture of measurement my a culture of
measurement now those who those who
enjoy asking people to fill in the
documents to fill in the spreadsheets to
get to collect as many numbers as
possible might say well you know we're
we're trying to automate we're trying to
simplify we're trying to make sure all
the information is easily accessible and
in one place you're suggesting actually
you're creating some needless work a lot
of the time and and I think the the
really interesting thing about your
thesis is are your resources going to
the people who actually do what the
company's supposed to do provide the the
product that that the company wants to
provide or is it going to all the red
tape within the organization that
sometimes slows those things down well
put beautifully I'm a very eminent
academic I know said that um when he
first joined the history faculty at the
University of Cambridge the entire
faculty was run by as he described it a
middle-aged woman who knew everything
and he said he looks at The Faculty now
and there are more administrators than
there are
historians so those of us in our 50s
have seen this trend over our working
lives I think I think people who've come
in recently into the into the off into
office life or indeed into the public
sector where it's perhaps even more
acute haven't noticed this trend but
anybody in their 50s or above will have
seen since they started work in the 80s
and the '90s that this trend seems kind
of
inexorable are you measuring the right
things are you optimizing for the right
things and is a kind of um culture of
what you might call pseudo
efficiency where you're trying to
optimize the parts rather than
optimizing the hole is this actually
good um because I mean you know one of
the great lessons of w Edward steings
was if you want to optimize the whole
you have to sub optimize the
parts and yet what we have is we have
this culture of what you might call
pseudo efficiency that creeps into every
single pocket of corporate life or
indeed institutional life and it's
always directed at the people doing
useful work not at the bureaucracy
itself and my claim is that this has led
to a kind of sovietization of of
capitalism well let me ask you Rory uh
my last question to you is what would
your advice to workers who are under the
thumb of the Box ticking be how should
they rebel against the Box tickers well
my claim is that to some extent the
working from home phenomenon is an act
of rebellion most people in knowledge
work aren't unionized they have no
capacity for collective bargaining but
they did discover that after the
pandemic it was quite difficult for an
employer to sack everybody
simultaneously and I one thing I would
argue for actually to a large extent is
that um campaigning for uh
liberalization of working hours and
practices and locations is a sensible
win-win if you look at it in the right
mindset okay maybe people are 3% less
productive if they work from home as one
statistic showed okay well in which case
just ask them to work half an hour
longer every day okay you know it the
the whole point of capitalism is it's
not actually a process of efficiency
optimization it's a process of discovery
it's it should be pursued in a way much
closer to detective work and
investigation
uh than uh as it has become a kind of
process of you know basically cost
cutting dressed up in fancy
language and you know as a perfectly
enthusiastic capitalist I see the
discovery of new forms of value exchange
if employees actually value flexibility
and autonomy uh more than they value
money okay that should be an opportunity
in fact to generate new value that you
can reward people and apart from
anything else okay
um I think London without some sort of
georgist escape from the strangle hold
of London property prices I think a lot
of these uh London knowledge businesses
uh effectively destroying the lives of
their young people if if I look at our
young staff uh after we pay them you
know every incremental pound we pay them
40 40% will go in tax of what's left
over about 50% will go in uh
accommodation and transport costs
commuting costs and accommodation that's
an appallingly inefficient way to reward
people because you're really rewarding
London's buy toet landlords with every
pound you give them as much as you're
rewarding them and I I I don't I don't
think we're shrewd enough in spotting uh
you know in looking at efficiency in a
broad enough context what efficiency
means in rewarding people is you reward
people and a large amount of that money
goes to them and we've created stupid
world where we demand people recent
graduates live in the most expensive
real estate on the planet and
effectively the capacity to actually
enrich people has more or less gone but
it's not helped by the fact that no
financially driven organization will
ever sit down and go what are the
reasons for paying some of our staff
more it's also not helped by politicians
either who s a lot of that red tape Rory
thanks so much for joining spectator TV
thank you
that's it for this week once again if
you enjoy spectator TV do subscribe to
our YouTube channel just click the
Subscribe button at the bottom of this
video and tap the Bell icon to make sure
you never miss an episode thanks again
for watching and do join us again next
[Music]
week